retour premier tour donc forcément
j'irai joue sur deuxième bon là pour eux
pour essayer de une amélioration que
dans la vie de tous les jours je n'ai
pas voté parce que je trouve que c'est
trop près par rapport au corps 19 donc
je pense que l'idéal ce serait de
reporter sa septembre octobre
et bien moi je trouve que c'est
pertinent parce que pour l'instant il ya
plein de budget en sus temps aux
décisions ne peuvent pas être prises
il y a des gens qui attendent vraiment
des équipements pour leur ville et ça
peut pas rester en suspens comme ça
pendant six mois des tensions c'est en
septembre on
il faut en terminer avec ce second tour
après il ya la question aux sanitaires
qui se pose alors personnellement je ne
me questionne encore je suis pas certain
d'aller voter
après tout dépend des conditions dans
lesquelles nous irons voter sur le
procès dieter ce qui m'agace c'est qu'il
ya 36 points 36 mesure alors vous pouvez
aller voter moi je peux pas aller
travailler parce que je suis serveuse
enfin c'est un véritable pataquès on
s'en fout
j'irai pas voilà c'est des guignols